[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand huit et des territoires avec
l'ensemble des chaînes partenaires
répartis sur tout le territoire français
nous allons faire un tour d'horizon
mesurer l'impact de cette pandémie et
surtout souligner les meilleures
initiatives les solidarités qui nest à
l'occasion de cette crise avec la sortie
du déconfinement wulff avait programmé
le 11 mai prochain l'école et le travail
devrait reprendre petit à petit dans ce
processus un peu complexe les
collectivités locales auront un rôle
absolument déterminant et sur le bassin
d'arcachon vous allez le voir en gironde
le palais des congrès s'est transformé
en atelier de couture
plus de 100 personnes travaillent pour
fabriquer des masques
ces masques tant recherchée et
commandées par l'agglomération de
bordeaux christophe chaluleau de tv7 la
chaîne du groupe sud ouest a pu assister
à la fabrication de ces masques regard
des lieux habituels dédié à
l'événementiel le parc des expositions
de la teste a trouvé une toute autre
destination guerre contre le coc vite 19
oblige c'est une véritable usine de
textile qui s'est monté ici en quelques
jours avec un seul objectif fabriquer
plus de 30 mille masques par jour
destiné à la métropole bordelaise et
plus largement aux départements gironde
a laissé leur de travail par jour je
pense que l'équipe est en passe d'être
de multiplier par deux le nombre
d'agents sur site et donc de doubler
purement et simplement la production
faisait en faisant de 8 ou tout
simplement ce qu'ils méritaient de
passer à près de 50 masques par jour ce
qui devient vraiment extrêmement
compétitif et qui va répondre à une
attente
vous comprenez bien que dans 4 semaines
produire quasiment 80 millions de
masques en france ça va quand même si
gageure nous sommes dans une période de
l'unité nationale où il faut aider avant
tout nos concitoyens dans le cas d'une
crise sanitaire
donc peu importe les collectivités peu
importe les étiquettes politiques ce qui
nous importe à ce moment en ce moment
c'est vraiment de nous entendre et de
faire en sorte que demain tout les
girondines et où les girondins puissent
est équipé d'un masque à minima une
initiative locale de l'entreprise valen
installé au teich qui emploie ici
majoritairement des couturières au
chômage
nous avons la compétence est donc
maintenant c'est un formidable défi
finalement industriel et pas seulement
c'est aussi une très grande action de
solidarité
une chaîne humaine extraordinaire et
donc on est dans quelque chose qu'on
n'avait jamais imaginé ce sont ainsi 2
millions de masques qui ont été
commandés sur quatre sites différents
afin de pouvoir subvenir aux premiers
besoins nécessaires après le 11 mai
voilà il n'y a pas que des masques que
l'on fabrique en france bien sûr on en
commande par millions un arrivage a eu
lieu ces tout derniers jours sous haute
surveillance d'ailleurs à l'aéroport de
vatry entre troyes et reims c'est là la
plaque tournante des livraisons sur
notre territoire nos partenaires de
canal 32 ont pu se rendre sur place pour
regarder concrètement comment se passait
ses livraisons ces photos de la première
livraison du milliard de masques
commandés par la france à la chine ont
été prises à l'aéroport de vatry
ce pont aérien a débuté le 30 mars il
devrait se poursuivre jusqu'à début juin
pour son directeur l'aéroport de vatry à
gagner cet appel d'offres car la
structure est parfaitement appropriée et
rodez pour la logistique d'urgence et
sanitaire entre le parking avions et
leurs chargements des camions on est sur
200 mètres linéaires donc ce qui nous
donne en fait en termes de déchargement
d'un avion jusqu au chargement de
l'ensemble des camions donc c'est pour
on va dire une cargaison de 100 tonnes
on va mettre à peu près trois heures
pour l'ensemble des opérations soit deux
fois moins de temps que ses concurrents
avec trois mille huit cent soixante
mètres la piste figurent parmi les plus
longues d'europe
elle permet l'atterrissage des plus gros
porteurs 25 à 30 personnels expérimentés
se charge de récupérer leurs cargaisons
les douaniers contrôler les colis par
échantillons tous sont habitués à
effectuer leurs tâches sous la
surveillance étroite de leurs mets du
papier fiduciaire par exemple
donc ça c'est des choses qui demandent
un niveau de sécurité très élevé on a
aussi du matériel militaire donc on a
d'habitude de la présence des militaires
sur le site aussi on a du fret sensible
aérospatiale aussi sur ce type d'avion
on peut traiter environ 100 tonnes de
fret par avion ça représente environ 10
millions de masques de savoir que
bientôt parler on va accueillir
l'antonov 225 qui lui est le plus gros
avion du monde est là on va pouvoir
doubler la capacité donc recevoir
quasiment 20 millions de masques en une
seule fois cette opération recentre
batterie sur sa fonction première le
fret les met en valeur son savoir faire
sur la scène internationale c'est
important pour nous parce que d'abord on
est présent sur les réseaux sociaux
chinois
à cette occasion nous mêmes partenaires
chinois aujourd'hui sont dans le dans le
projet de mettre en place des avions non
pas pour le e-commerce mais en fait pour
répondre aux demandes de masques pour
l'heure les masques de la commande
d'état sont immédiatement répartis sous
escorte auprès des cinq entrepôts de
santé publique france l'aéroport de
vatry sert également de plateforme de
transit pour les commandes régional de
masques ou grâce à ces chambres froides
la réception de produits pharmaceutiques
les personnes les plus fragiles sont
telles contraintes de rester confinés
beaucoup plus longtemps comme l'a
annoncé le président de la république
dans son allocution sera surtout le cas
probablement des personnes qui résident
dans les ehpad de nombreuses initiatives
commencent à être un peu partout afin
qu'elles puissent garder ce lien avec
leur famille
c'est le cas à metz en moselle où une
association a lancé une cagnotte pour
équiper ses établissements en tablette
numérique
regardez le reportage de nos confrères
devient mirabel sur place il les
attendait avec impatience 30 tablettes
numériques à destination des amap à de
moselle doté d'un simple logiciels de
téléconférence
elle devrait permettre de rompre avec
l'isolément des personnes âgées des
résidences peuvent en a plein la tuque
salon et une fois que ce salon est créé
un code est transmis aux familles et des
familles n'ont qu'à rejoindre le site
appuyez sur rejoindre le salon utiliser
numéro que l'établissement leur aura
donné et la visioconférence se lance
l'écran est plus important qu'à
téléphone après ça permet aussi pour les
personnes âgées qui ont des problèmes
aussi de vue de pouvoir plus facilement
visionner et à interagir avec la famille
en face et ça évite justement d'avoir
aux personnes à se déplacer de manière
très sécurisée et en respectant les
règles sanitaires
les 30 tablettes seront répartis sur les
quinze ehpad du groupe 750 personnes
devraient pouvoir en bénéficier
de quoi rassurer les résidents et leurs
familles les grands verres s'ennuie
après leur famille mais les familles
s'ennuie après leur grand mère il ya
déjà des petites choses qui se font il
ya des lettres il ya des dessins
d'enfants
on a des échanges de ce type et les
familles sont très demandeuses et en
plus elle n'habite pas toutes
obligatoirement autour d'eux et pas mana
qui sont loin anglais sa magnifique
cadeau pour pour pallier ces grandes
distances et puis à ce confinement qui
est un petit peu difficile à vivre pour
nos personnes âgées 120 autres tablettes
seront offertes aux ehpad du luxembourg
et de la moselle des tablettes financé
par les 5100 euros de dons reçus par la
fondation solidarité créée par 20
informaticiens c'était leur manière de
contribuer en fait on cherchait depuis
un long moment à nous rendre utiles
un peu comme beaucoup de personnes et on
n'avait pas de sollicitations on a eu
l'idée justement d'amener notre
compétence professionnelle à destination
des établissements qui pourraient en
avoir besoin et en l'occurrence mais par
rapport à ce confinement est strict
c'était ce qui nous est venue en tête de
prime abord ces résidents de maisons de
retraite
je conçois des proches à nous soit des
familles qu'on connaît tous des amis
sont soit fortement concernée par par la
distance humaine avec avec leurs proches
la moselle compte plus de 240 mille
personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans si le
11 mai devrait marquer le début du dix
confinement annoncé par emmanuel macron
les personnes âgées pourraient rester
confinées jusqu'à la fin de l'année
ces tablettes devraient donc leur
permettre de garder le lien avec leurs
proches
autre annonce d' emmanuel macron
maintenant près de quatre millions de
foyers vont bénéficier d'une aide
exceptionnelle le site actus.fr nos
partenaires nous explique les détails de
cette annonce
comme vous le voyez sur cet écran la
prime serait calqué sur l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire
sont concernés les familles les plus
modestes avec enfants qui pourront
toucher jusqu'à 150 euros
et si vous voulez en savoir un peu plus
regardez ce site actus.fr vous aurez
tous les informations toutes les
explications concernant les détails de
cette prime depuis le début de cette
crise de nombreuses initiatives
solidaires ont vu le jour notamment en
haute savoie et en savoie c'est le cas
du lycée louis-armand de chambéry qui a
transformé ses unités de fabrication
chimique et pharmaceutique en atelier de
production de gel et de solutions
hydro-alcooliques
regardez ce reportage de sébastien
germain pour 8 mont blanc qui s'est
rendu sur place
nous ne sommes pas dans une usine ou
dans un laboratoire mais bien dans une
salle de cour du lycée louis-armand de
chambéry d'habitude ces professeurs
utilisent ses unités de fabrication à
des fins pédagogiques
désormais pour jouer un rôle concret
dans la lutte contre la propagation du
cobp et 19
il fabrique du gel et de la solution
hydroalcoolique oui ça nous semblait
important de pouvoir aider
et c'était réalisable sur notre plateau
aussi dans ce contexte un peu
particulier là nous on s'est tout de
suite positionné que nos élèves parce
qu'on savait qu'on était capables de
fabriquer facilement de la solution
hydroalcoolique donc on a démarré le
projet avec nos élèves en laboratoire et
sur plateau technique c'est vrai qu on
est occupé pendant toute la journée du
coup on évite de penser à autre chose
c'est sûr que et puis c'est le sentiment
de pouvoir aider aux deux fois par
semaine ces six professeurs qui assure
par ailleurs la continuité pédagogique
auprès de leurs élèves arrivent à
produire entre 1500 et 2000 litres par
jour de fabrication avec une recette
assez simple en la matière première est
un alcool généralement d'éthanol ou
foires d eau propre à nole
on y ajoute de l'oxygéner et de la
glycérine la glycérine c'est l'agent qui
rend les mains un petit peu douces pour
pas que l'alcool soit trop agressif
voilà et puis on a une particularité à
leur ment c'est qu'on fabrique nous
mêmes notre eau distillée
voilà donc on a dans l'atelier dans
lequel nous sommes
huit pilotes de génie chimique donc
chacun s'attache donc rim tâche qui est
dévolu pour pouvoir s'organiser la façon
la plus efficiente possible
aujourd'hui la machine est parfaitement
huilée au sein de l'établissement qui
accueille d'ordinaire jusqu'à 1500
élèves une fois produit le gel et la
solution hydroalcoolique sont ensuite
acheminés vers les ateliers mécaniques
transformer le temps du confinement en
entrepôt de stockage et vu les
difficultés actuelles pour se procurer
une telle denrées l'établissement est
aujourd'hui victime de son succès moi je
découvre des hommes des femmes tout à
fait exceptionnel a commencé cette
aventure à la destinée des soignants à
la destinée des personnes qui avaient
besoin de cette solution de façon
intimiste et local c'est-à-dire sur
grand chambéry et la ville de chambéry
les demandes sont énormes
ce sont des demandes qui sont à la fois
globalement porté par les personnes qui
sont en contact du public et donc nous
sommes auprès des institutions de toutes
les institutions et nous avons quasiment
une cinquantaine de demandes par jour
l'illustration ce jour là avec de
nombreux clients présents sur place pour
se réapprovisionner grâce à une formule
de drive sommes une entreprise est là en
fait je fais un regroupement et je vais
aller
comment essayer randonnée à dix autres
entreprises aussi parce que comment on
allait derrière de sanitaires et pour
nos employés il faut absolument qu'on
ait de la solution pour qu'ils puissent
se désinfecter les mains ou ça met en
lumière vraiment le côté volontariat des
équipes du lycée on a vraiment
l'impression quand on arrive au lycée on
est dans un milieu je dirais semi
professionnel voire professionnels aussi
bien sur le process de fabrication que
sur le process de livraison à son
échelle le lycée louis-armand de
chambéry symbolise parfaitement les
nombreux élan de solidarité
mais ces dernières semaines dans nos
départements cette crise réserve souvent
bien des surprises direction les vosges
maintenant depuis le début du
confinement
la demande d eux a explosé nous en
consommons beaucoup plus au quotidien
notamment pour faire des gâteaux de peur
de pénurie les grandes enseignes en ont
commandé d'ailleurs en masse
conséquence les producteurs ne peuvent
plus suivre
regardez toutes les explications au
sujet de cette très grande consommation
des français en neuf
avec nos confrères de vie à vos sur
place oui mais à combien par jour en
moyenne à peu près 180 presse par jour
là on va en avoir un petit peu moins
parce qu'elle pendant toute la journée
pas jusqu'où je touche jusqu'à 14 heures
après ça se calme en quelques minutes si
noémie va ainsi ramassé plus de 139 de
son petit élevage de poules de plein air
chaud musée un complément de salaire
avec une denrée très recherché depuis le
confinement à demande en effet enflé
mais la jolie rousse ne peut obstruer
mans au mieux qu'un neuf par jour
le cheptel de 200 galimant ci a donc du
mal à répondre à la demande locale
alors oui on est en fait la pompe du
jour et vendu dans la journée et quand
j'en ai plus bas je prends des fêtes des
réservations pour les jours d'après mary
luy ya beaucoup de demandes des poules
donc toujours autant mais par contre la
demande à a bien augmenté
qu'est ce que vous disent les gens
pourquoi il en veut plus aujourd'hui bas
parce qu'ils font beaucoup utilisé
beaucoup par eux mêmes donc il fallait
beaucoup de pâtisseries par eux mêmes du
coup c'est pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de
demandes et puis aussi il évite d'aller
dans les supermarchés donc il se
rapproche des petits producteurs locaux
une activité annexe pour noémie connu
pour avoir développé la première ferme
quoi paunic de la région ce système qui
permet l'élevage de poissons et la
production de légumes les uns à
nourrissant les autres petites
productions duff donc ici écoulée en
vente directe rien à voir à quelques
kilomètres de là avec cet élevage dont
nous avions suivi l'installation à uv xi
24 mille poules pondeuses bio une
exploitation sous contrat avec le groupe
cdp aux bases et dans la marne qui
connaît et maîtrise le circuit de l'oeuf
en france les chiffres l'attestent 4
millions de poules 1 milliards 50
millions de produits à destination
unique de la grande distribution nous
avons joint le patron qui nous
expliquent cette chasse à l'oeuf sous
l'ère qu'ovide jusqu'à 350 % de hausse
de la demande dans certaines grandes
surfaces
je dois avouer que la demande telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui on a on ne l'a
jamais connu le consommateur si vous
voulez pas cherché lui à se
réapprovisionner en d'une façon un peu
il a eu un peu peur de la pénurie donc
il va il va faire du stock de l'autre
côté nous avons le chef de rayon qui
pour être sûr d'être eux d'avoir ce
qu'il veut va demander plus que ce qu'il
a réellement besoin d'une poule c en
gros 300 aux parents c'est à peu près 1
tous les dix jours que l'on n'ait besoin
ou pas besoin boeuf la poule elle
prendra la même quantité les yeux pour
les présenter il faut des boîtes c'était
boîtes elles viennent de france ou
d'ailleurs et les usines aujourd'hui
fabricants les boîtes de toute façon au
pareil que quelques pourcentages de
croissance supplémentaire donc de toute
façon aujourd'hui nous on doit livrer à
peu près à à 105% raidir de notre volume
habituel on sait pas faire mieux une
tension sur le marché qui pourrait donc
durer sachant que la france est l'un des
plus grands pays consommateurs au monde
avec 229 par an et par habitant
c'est la protéine la moins chère du
marché nous expliquent les
professionnels
voilà après les oeufs des vosges les
asperges d'occitanie les prix flambent 6
euros le kilo pour la petite tige verte
contre 3 euros l'an dernier à la même
époque
une aubaine d'ailleurs pour les
agriculteurs du gard vous vous en doutez
mais une situation qui est pas très
agréable et bénéfique pour les
consommateurs
les détails avec ce reportage devient
occitanie regard des juges l'hydro pour
les mets un peu pour désinfecter la
machine à carte bleue quand on fait des
benjamins a tout ce qu'il faut ce
producteurs gardois qui cultive en ce
moment des asperges dans les gorges du
gardon s'est dotée d'équipements
sanitaires
on dirait une culotte mais impossible de
les utiliser dans les champs c'est très
compliqué quoi légal suffoque dans les
masques là vous savez quand vous avez
dit claude un événement que de l'autre
vous avez cherché une asperge dans une
lutte assez clair assez physique
contrairement à d'habitude les ouvriers
arrivent à chacun avec leur voiture
d'habitude et arrivent ensemble et on
essaie de les mettre
chacun le poser dans un champ qui soit
pas trop trois côtés des mesures
improvisées donc le masque
il le garde pour le centre de tri et la
vente d'ailleurs ce n'est pas le seul
changement dans le quotidien de benjamin
en pleine épidémie de cours aux navires
us le prix de vente des tiges verte et
violette aussi évolué et cette année
c'est 6 euros en moyenne le kilo auprès
de deux grandes surfaces de la région
toulousaine et dans les marchés de gros
des bouches du rhône
l'année dernière c'était entre 3 et 4
euros seulement
ce nouveau prix lui permet enfin de
vivre correctement situation même
ubuesque les supermarchés gardois qui
jusqu'ici ils ignoraient l'exploitant
sont en manque de marchandise et
viennent aujourd'hui frappé à sa porte
peut-être pas tous les poèmes sur son
niveau maraîchage et fruits et légumes
l'europe nous a fait mal ça on s'en rend
compte aujourd'hui parce que là
aujourd'hui qui a quasiment plus de la
marchandise car entre nous on arrive
très bien à vendre notre jeu ce qui
n'était pas le cas en début de saison
son cas n'est pas isolé la fédération
nationale des agriculteurs du gard le
remarque le rapport de force a
clairement évolué entre les grandes
surfaces et les producteurs français
autant que vos oreilles d'or français
que les gms si nous augmentons mono
qu'on peut y aider
on peut arriver à produire 500 français
à vendre 100% français il faut trouver
des accords un petit locaux un petit peu
commerciaux on est d accord mais tout le
monde y arrive donc on irait vers le
christ pourquoi pas deux et il n'y a pas
que les grandes surfaces qui font de
l'oeil à nos producteurs les gens
eux-mêmes confiné sont de plus en plus
nombreux à consommer local directement
une plateforme a même été créé par la
région occitanie pour valoriser et
livrer les marchandises de nos
producteurs locaux
voilà autre impact du coc vite 19 cette
fois ci sur les animaux les eaux pousse
un cri d'alarmé
malgré le confinement et les mesures
sanitaires ils doivent continuer bien
sûr de nourrir leurs animaux
les revenus sont devenus inexistants
puisqu'on ne peut plus les visiter
une situation très préoccupante pour les
professionnels nos confrères de
télénantes se sont rendus au zoo de la
boissière
regardez ce reportage cela devait être
la grande nouveauté 2020 au zoo de la
boissière du doré le royaume des lions
une extension du parc de deux hectares
et une passerelle longue de 200 m pour
observer les félins dans leur élément
un investissement record de plus d'un
million d'euros
hélas ça jamais été ouvert encore c'est
une nouvelle partie qui aurait dû ouvrir
le 27 mars
une situation inédite pour le zoo depuis
le début du confinement
les portes sont restées fermées au
public résultat aucune recette de
billetterie aucune recette d'hébergement
manque à gagner estimé
huit cent cinquante mille euros sur les
deux prochains mois pendant ce temps au
zoo la vie continue les naissances aussi
visiteurs ou pas la charge de travail
est identique pour les soigneurs un peu
gourmand de chômage technique non on
connaît pas parce que va tout simplement
travaille avec du vivant
il faut s'en occuper tous les jours et
puis bah on est content - ça nous fait
un peu de sorties au nous de rester à la
maison et coup nourriture est ce les
mêmes les coûts d'entretien des animaux
avec le personnel animalier reste le
même
et puis
les coûts vétérinaire évidemment rester
aussi les mêmes pour nous le virus ou
pas virus on doit s'occuper des animaux
comme d'habitude pour faire vivre le
parquer les animaux chaque mois la
facture s'élève à 215 milles euros
manque de trésorerie oblige la seule
solution pour les parcs se tourner vers
les banques
forcément c'est de l'endettement
supplémentaire qui va forcément avoir de
l'impact sur le futur proche puisque qui
dit endettement supplémentaire dit dis
peut-être moins d'investissements pour
les mois ou les ou l'année prochaine
tout simplement pour retrouver un peu
d'oxygène d'ici à la réouverture le zoo
a lancé une cagnotte en ligne plus de
16000 euros ont d'ores et déjà été
récoltés voilà dans ce grand jt des
territoires nous recevront dorénavant
chaque fois un responsable de la presse
quotidienne régionale ou d'une
télévision locale afin de regarder de
quelle manière ces médias ont été
impactés par cette pandémie
bonjour hubert coudurier vous êtes le
directeur de l'information le président
de tébéo et de tb sud pour jour celui de
vigueur alors hubert coudurier bien sûr
expliquez nous comment vous traverser
cette crise du coronavirus comment
fonctionne vos équipes sur place en
bretagne a joué au télégramme
on a appliqué les mesures classiques un
de chômage partiel pour certains mais
finalement peut-être moins que dans des
secteurs particuliers en attaque t comme
la publicité au niveau de l'information
je tiens pas tout tout le monde est sur
le pont mais nous avons quand même
aujourd'hui
malgré tout ceux qui sont en télétravail
encore beaucoup d'éditeurs qui
travaillent au siège et nous avons
réduit par contre le nombre d'éditions
qui sont passées de 19 à 4 alors hubert
coudurier vous êtes à la fois directeur
de l'information du télégramme président
de tbwa tv sud les deux chaînes tnt de
bretagne comment fonctionne le journal
au quotidien avec les chaînes
elles-mêmes
comment fonctionnent les équipes entre
elles alors niveau des chaînes de
télévision évidemment nous sommes en
effectif très réduit
néanmoins nous avons réussi à mater
agité quotidien moi même j'ai mis la
main à la pâte et mon émission mon
interview hebdomadaire est devenue
quotidienne et nous avons considéré que
c'est dans cette période particulière
que les chaînes locales doivent faire la
démonstration qu elles sont
incontournables
parallèlement nous nous essayons de
rapprocher le journal de la télévision
d'intégrer la télévision dans le journal
dans la mesure où on souhaite à terme
constituer un réseau peut-être à travers
d'une chaîne numérique terrestre mais un
réseau digne de ce nom qui soit capable
de faire le pendant de france 3 et de
toutes les chaînes d'information qui
existe et hubert coudurier comment voyez
vous la sortie de cette crise comment
voyez-vous l'avenir immédiat pour des
titres comme les vôtres pour des chaînes
de télévision comme les vôtres nous
avions une course avec le crédit mutuel
cic
nous avions relancer la transat anglaise
qui devait partir de brest début mais ce
ne sera pas le cas mais néanmois nos
sponsors nous accompagnerons quand cet
événement sera reprogrammée
nous avons également avec nos
partenaires de morgane productions lélie
des francofolies qui sont en danger mais
nous espérons bien au sein du groupe
pouvoir maintenir une activité
d'information forte et qui permettent de
faire de l'information locale et
régionale
la priorité voilà merci hubert coudurier
merci si elle veillait vous étiez en
direct de brest dans votre chaîne tébéo
et puis regardez comment le plus grand
quotidien régional français ouest france
met en lumière ce qu'il appelle les
solidaires dans une édition spéciale ce
week-end françois xavier le franc le
rédacteur en chef du plus grand
quotidien français remercie dans un
éditorial en première page ces femmes et
ces hommes qui écrit-il retroussent
leurs manches pour aider et pour servir
ce sont huit pages spéciales dommage
offerte avec le journal et ce titre de
une
solidaires avec un point d'exclamation
et pour conclure notre jt comme chaque
semaine ce sont vos initiatives vos
gestes de solidarité qui nous intéresse
vous les exposés sur les réseaux sociaux
et le zapping des solidarités proposés
par nos confrères de la boîte à
histoires nous les roms est mort pour
cette semaine regarder
[Musique]
c'est devenu on est au top au pardon un
matin aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que ça vous dirait pas con
notre manière l'important de soutien
auprès des hôpitaux notre objectif
annoncé
on propose 2 x 120 formule pour pétain
le mercredi le vendredi
[Musique]
voilà merci d'avoir suivi ce grand jt
des territoires sur vos chaînes locales
et régionales et sur tv5 monde on se
retrouve bientôt pour une prochaine
édition
surtout bon courage à tous au revoir
[Musique]